-My next guest is a four-time
Olympic gold-medal gymnast
who's hoping to win even more at
the Tokyo Olympics this summer.
Please welcome Simone Biles!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Simone! Ah! So good to see ya!
-Thank you, you too.
-We're gearing up
for the Olympics.
It's less than 100 days.
I'm assuming
you're training like mad.
What is -- For me, training
is putting on gym clothes,
thinking about it, and then
going, "Ah, I don't have time.
I really have to get to work."
[ Laughter ]
That's about my training.
-Right, right. I wish.
-Yeah. Similar schedules?
[ Laughter ]
-I wish, but, unfortunately,
I train seven hours a day.
I do have Sundays off.
So, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
Friday, I train twice a day.
And then Thursday and Saturday,
I train once a day.
-Now, you normally
have a fun nickname.
The Final Five, right?
-Yes.
-But this year, the team
is four people, correct?
-Right.
-So it can't be Final Five.
-Yes, it's four.
We definitely don't know
what we're going to be
or who is going to be
on the team yet.
It's always so much fun for
the audience and the fans to try
to pick or guess the name
that we picked.
I remember in 2016,
after we made the team,
we all collectively thought of
a name, and then we announced it
when we won team gold.
So that was just our strategy
for that one,
but it's also fun because fans
get to remember those teams
that have certain names
and it's easier for them
to recall who's on which team.
-I'm wondering can we guess --
We have an audience here.
I'm trying to predict --
the Fab Four.
You could do that.
-Okay, we could do that.
I'll keep it in my pocket.
-Well, I got zero applause,
so let's scratch that.
Let's scratch that. Wow.
Didn't expect that response
from the audience.
Nothing. I got no applause.
Nothing.
So how about Fantastic Four?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. Oh, they like that one.
-They like that one.
I should maybe stop there.
Four Door?
[ Laughter ]
-The Four Door? Okay.
-Yeah, the Four Door,
because you're gonna slam it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey!
-When you go to the Olympics.
The Four Door.
Thank you.
I'm gonna stop there.
I want to talk to you about
your docuseries.
Talk to me about this --
"Simone vs. Herself."
-Mm-hmm.
-What is this all about?
What are people going to see
when they check this out?
-Me just taking myself
to new heights in the gym,
trying new skills, a little bit
of a look inside my life,
because I feel like people
always think
I'm always training,
but besides that,
I have a lot of amazing partners
that I work with.
So I get to share my time
in between there,
but it's not all glitz and glam.
Sometimes we have to get
down and dirty in the gym,
so it's just a look at my life.
-You're just a great role model
for --
-Well, thank you.
-For humans, for everybody.
But I have two little girls,
and they love you.
And you are in so many books
that they're reading about,
so they're flipping out
that you're on the show.
-Aww.
-Do you have any, like, words
for -- not my girls.
I'll ask you for that later.
"Can you leave a message?
I'm just going to call them
right now."
[ Laughter ]
What is your message
to young women out there?
-Yeah, of course.
I would definitely say it
doesn't matter where you start.
It's where you are going and how
you pick yourself back up
from those falls,
and just dream big
and then dream bigger
after that,
'cause you never know where
your dream will take you.
-I love that!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dream big, dream bigger.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here is Simone Biles
in the Facebook Watch docuseries
"Simone vs. Herself."
Take a look.
-I'm, like walking in, like two
minutes before practice starts.
I'm like, "Who am I?
This is so unlike me,
but I seriously just can't get
up anymore."
-Next break.
-It's a very different change.
But I still go in there
and get my work done.
-She does what she has to
be doing in training.
She will be very, very fit.
There is no issue with that.
It's the mental.
She will be
the number-one attraction
for Team USA over there.
A lot of pressure
in her shoulders.
But we're going to try to
take all the pressure away
from her and just to focus on
what is controllable,
and it's her own gymnastics.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh! Amazing!
Simone Biles!
-Thank you.